[Música]
pues mi diosa hablar de
de la inmortalidad
espero que lo comprenda la gente no
[Música]
últimamente participado en varios
debates sobre el envejecimiento y la
inmortalidad
y esto es un tema que para la gente
joven debería tener su tremendo
atractivo
el pensar que en efecto la longevidad
está aumentando y aumentar nadie sabe
hasta qué punto hay gente que piensa que
viviremos de promedio según los 100 años
entre el poco tiempo la gente que piensa
que en futuras generaciones se podría
llegar pues a vivir 120 y más años
hay algún límite nadie lo sabe hay gente
que opina que por una serie de razones
física
y biológica más de 120 o 125 no podremos
vivir pero es una idea que está siendo
fuertemente cuestionada
si cambiamos realmente el estilo de vida
s cambiamos
y aumentamos la calidad del ejercicio
físico y sobre todo si mantenemos un
alto grado de ejercicio intelectual y de
curiosidad intelectual pues realmente en
ese aspecto no tendríamos porqué tener
ni aceptar ningún límite inmediato
este tema nos obliga a repensar casi
todo
la idea de la muerte va a ser una idea a
la cual le vamos a tener que dar cierta
importancia
hasta ahora el estudio de la muerte
parecía como un estudio innecesario uno
se muere y ya está bueno ahora habrá que
pensar qué es la muerte para qué sirve
la muerte
si está estudiando el tema de la
criogenización que es decirles llevar
los cuerpos a un nivel de frío tal que
se mantengan prácticamente con muchas
constantes vitales en funcionamiento en
espera de que haya movimientos que
permitan un día revivir a esa persona se
dice yo no lo confirmado pero se me
afirmaba en los colegios que hay una
persona criogenizado en alemania y que
hay muchas peticiones hablan de más de
30 peticiones de gente que quiere
criogenizado especialmente de padres o
madres
que tengan niños muy pequeños que han
muerto y que piensen que creo
generándoles pues se llegará un momento
en que esas enfermedades que tuvieran se
puedan eliminar y esos niños puedan
vivir solamente este tema la idea de que
una persona muerta pueda revivir ya
empieza a destruir muchas formas de
pensar y de entender la vida
yo creo que estos son el tipo de temas
en donde poco a poco vamos a tener que
investigar a fondo
esta universidad la nebrija con la que
yo vengo teniendo una relación realmente
amorosa desde hace mucho tiempo me
parece que es el tipo de universidad que
requiere estos tiempos es por el plantón
universidad joven está dispuesto a
afrontar estos temas está dispuesta a
afrontar prácticamente cualquier tema y
eso es en definitiva una riqueza que los
estudiantes de la nebrija tendréis que
valorar el que sea joven y el que no
tenga miedo a ningún tipo de pensamiento
mucho
y es que la resistencia al cambio aunque
no lo creamos forma parte de la
humanidad la humanidad ha estado
permanentemente resistiéndose al cambio
aunque lo que hemos visto y pensando
desde los orígenes de la humanidad hasta
ahora no es otra cosa que cambios
algunos de ellos incluso violentos y
profundos sea las reglas generales de la
vida
vamos a hablar esos temas sin miedo
vamos a hablar de estos temas sin el
menor problema
sobre todo sin la menor limitación
mental yo creo que estamos en la época
en que al menos poder hablar tenemos que
empezar a poder hablar de todo y volver
a poder a poner en cuestión todo
sino la gente se va a aburrir y no hay
nada peor que los aburrimientos mentales
la política por ejemplo está penando ese
problema la política aburre
el debate de ayer ocurrió
fundamentalmente porque pues porque no
se mueven las ideas porque
el sistema de defensa y de ataque sigue
siendo el mismo
y la política tendrá que empezar a darse
cuenta de que empieza a ser más
atractiva o los jóvenes se despegaran
definitivamente de la de la política
en estos estudios sobre envejecimiento
intervienen tantos factores y tantas
disciplinas distintas que lo primero que
tenemos que entender ya ha hablado otras
veces en la universidad como de ésta es
que hay una pregunta y es así que eso lo
recomiendo a todos estudiantes que hay
que olvidarse la pregunta es la que nos
hacemos de vez en cuando diciendo usted
es de ciencias o de letras
esa pregunta tiene que desaparecer de la
universidad española
tenemos que ser de ciencias y de letras
no hay razón por la cual una persona que
tenga una tendencia a las letras no
pueda estudiar ciencias y lo mismo pasa
con los científicos los científicos
tienen que saber qué son las humanidades
yo creo que simplemente con ese salto ya
tendríamos una mente y unas mentes mucho
más dispuestas a afrontar el futuro de
una manera sensata
[Aplausos]